how tall am i in centimeters 32 no
[Music]
what's going on i'm kevin hart aka k
heart
aka the real deal um aka
that guy uh and i'm about to be quizzed
on the life
of the raindrop hey everybody what's
going on dwayne johnson here aka
the rock aka la aka
that guy i said that guy no but i said
it differently like
that guy all right enough stop this is
ridiculous now
there we go all right now i'm ready okay
all right complete dwayne's
twitter bio chivalrous gentlemen
just add
what are you talking about why would you
say that just add got it just add
what i love to drink fine
uh tequila saramonic okay my question
are you ready
complete kevin's twitter bio my name is
kevin hart and
i am a piece of [ __ ] come on stop it
that's nice
of [ __ ] in my bio in your bio i'm gonna
say i'm a piece of [ __ ]
buy it would you not say that in my bio
that's the kind of comedian you are
self-deprecating like that that's what
makes you brilliant no
i work hard there you go
that that's not in your body that's my
body what just says
i work hard yeah so that's like i'm
kevin hart i have a
heartbeat all right look i breathe air
if so that's not originally
johnson i drink tequila no what the [ __ ]
that's right i know but at least that's
fun yeah
that's that's somebody reads your bio
and goes wow yeah
he works hard guess what i'm dwayne rock
johnson uh yeah i'm a grown man
sometimes i drink
right that's good neither one of us
should get a point yes
maybe we should change we should change
tequila
okay all right biles will be changed
after the day
what is the name of dwayne's character
in jumanji welcome to the jungle
easy very easy smolder brave stone there
you go all right
there you go that's the point for me are
we keeping these i'll keep score
good because there's got to be a winner
what's the name of uh kevin hart's
character in jumanji
the next level oh uh dr
moose or mouse depends on who you ask uh
finn barr i mean it's it's right but
it's also wrong because
because it's franklin it's franklin it's
franklin okay miles finbar i mean you
said miles finbar
but franklin is a and i don't know like
i said i don't want to be a
but you know i know but just calling you
franklin i've never called you frank i'm
not telling this isn't about
you and i in the movie yeah i understand
that but my proper title
would be franklin you're right i'm
saying you're right you're right okay
he's right
we'll give him the point give him a
point i'm i'm not once again i'm not
trying to start
trouble or being started if they want to
give you a petty point then fine
take a pity point go ahead go ahead take
a point that you know you're not
supposed
to all right go ahead dwayne went to the
university of miami
uh what did he study while he was there
study what
what did you study like
like as in educate yourself it's in yes
man like yes
i tried to get better through my
textbooks and
wow um cars
changing batteries and cars it's gotta
be uh
no [ __ ] if it's a subject um all
right
let's take a crack at it communications
good communication that was a good
choice that's not it no no no
no i wanted to work for the cia
well thank god that didn't happen what
do you mean
what is that supposed to mean jesus
christ would be a great agent for the
agency yeah we've been in trouble
i said criminology
all right oh this is good you're going
to get this one this is too easy
what are you doing it's too easy oh okay
let's go to the hard ones
yeah you ready
okay this is a good one uh which concert
does kevin say
was the first concert he attended in his
life you got to know this one
let's break it down comedy yep got it
yep
uh you went to see a comedian or was it
a a group no
it was a group a group it was a group
kings of comedy sesame street on ice
when when you were a kid no
i was like 18 17 18. that's cool that's
a cool thing no need to judge it i'm not
judging it something i thought was cool
to do man
yeah let's do one more age yeah find a
good one dj i found a real good one
looking at those questions you probably
realize how uninteresting you are
completely wow
oh okay yeah this is a good one
in 2000 which rapper
did dwayne collaborate with on the
single
it doesn't matter
is that the song is that are you singing
a song yeah
it doesn't match the name of the song
where is that from it doesn't matter why
does that
what this why do you say it like that
who is who that's that is that that's
like iconic
with oprah it doesn't matter like see
well oprah does that when she gets out
of cars
it doesn't matter who you are you get a
car you get a car
you get a call oh she does do that but
she doesn't that's not
that's not no no no no no no no no
vanilla ice ice ice baby no it doesn't
it doesn't matter
if you like ice cream you're gonna eat
no
no what is it what is it white clef
remember
you know right
yeah okay okay but here one one more
because this is good
because you know um because you know how
how uh how good i was okay
what position did dwayne usually play
when he was part of the university of
miami football team
it's an easy question uh you got it
what's the i'm trying to think of a guy
like what are they called um they run
out and they put the football tee down
in the middle of the field before they
do the kickoffs what are they called
they take they there's the football tee
this guy runs out
like the equipment manager puts the t
out
and then gets back so he can get off the
field while they start playing
no no i actually played man like you
play all right you were on
yeah man you actually were in the games
um all right
let's take a crack at it you were you
were
a quarterback
dwayne and rock johnson no man
offensive tackle
[Laughter]
were you uh running back no no
the bo jackson of miami no that was not
me
what did you do you why rabbits tail
tail
tail end defensively hail in defense oh
man
linebacker's [ __ ] up live outside
outside tackle outside
yeah outside i don't know what you are
outside field outside field tackle last
one you gotta get this is it just gotta
get this one
uh according to google uh how tall is
kevin
okay this is good uh according to google
google yes
okay is this the legit answer because i
know it or is this do i [ __ ] with you on
this
which one go i think you should go for
what you know i'll go for what i know
legit answer legit legit legit because i
know you're my best friend
uh four foot two yes
right that's legit hey
you actually had me sold don't i sure
he's gonna get it no
come on okay okay i got it uh five six
five five no five four five four but
in in in centimeters what am i
centimeters
i don't even know what that
how is am i in centimeters 32 no
i'm 1.63 centimeters tall you guys know
each other as well as each other it was
a draw
it was a draw to draw god damn it damn
it
all right uh would you want to get
introduced
and then we'll do it and then the other
conversation better
i don't understand why it's better you
guys always
have a very good [ __ ] thing man y'all
do a good job guys
yes and the time it takes this rat to
eat a piece of popcorn
name three sports plays without a ball
uh boxing uh wrestling
jesus christ that rat's gonna die
he's gonna choke on that popcorn